bevor dies wieder losgeht weil es noch
kurz ein zwei sätze nicht los werden und
zwar ist dieses video nicht so wie meine
anderen videos sondern dass videos
einfach so spontan entstanden wir hatten
noch bocken video zu drehen und dadurch
seit dieses video entstanden
ich hab so wirklich überlegt ob ich das
hochladen aber das ding ist so mir geht
es ja auch einmal darum dass ich selber
zufrieden wenn mit dem videos
beziehungsweise selber drüber lachen
kann und bei dem video war es im schnitt
auf jeden fall so deswegen nimmt das
nicht alles so ernst
also eigentlich gar nicht aber was die
auch noch dazu sagen kann ihr wollt ja
immer dass youtube möglichst real sind
und dieses video ist wirklich so sind
wir halt auch in echt also manchmal so
wenn wir müde sind also ach komm scheiß
drauf verzichten auf ihr findet es ganz
witzig weil wir euch viel lachen
bisschen halt 8 ps absoluten wenn die
mal wieder bock habt auch so richtige
jungs mädchen videos wie ich das früher
gemacht hat dann lasst einfach mal
daumen nach oben da ich weiß nicht ob er
das so feiert ich hatte mal wieder bock
drauf
ob ihr das auch abwehr ich dann anhand
der rezension sehen jetzt viel spaß
hey leute was klappt jetzt willkommen
bei rein video ja aber ich für dieses
video heute für die leute ich freue mich
darauf weil ich weiß nicht das einfach
so ein thema werden jetzt so lange
überlegt was wir dazu sagen können und
was vielleicht nicht so gut wäre besser
und vor allem bin ich ja auch früher mit
diesen videos auf youtube bekannt
geworden sag ich mal oder diese videos
kann man sehr gut bei euch an und zwar
das freue mich immer gerade gab es
glaube ich bis jetzt noch gar nicht auf
jeden fall gab es bis jetzt nur noch gar
nicht so weit oder oder ja bald tun
bevor es losgeht wollte noch sagen ob
herab channel gibt es auch ein video und
geht auf jeden fall auf sein channel und
abonniert ihn weil wenn wir sehen es von
meinem channel mehr auf sein zimmer
gehen und ihn abonnieren da muss er eine
fette bestrafen machen das kommt er
nochmal extra video und dass er hätte
auch andersrum werfen mehr abonniert das
gehalt auf social blade oder so und die
die die an diesem tag denn die meisten
autos gemacht haben
der krieg nun bestrafen
ja auf jeden fall möchte auch gar nicht
fehlen heißt bei weiter drum herum und
ich würde sagen willkommen auch sofort
laufen punkt also wie gesagt heute
geht's zum thema was mädchen machen und
jungs lieben weil das ist wirklich eine
sache ja es ist nur unsere meinung und
die muss keiner vertreten vor allem kann
ich solche videos auf youtube mal
richtig cool und die gucke ich mir auch
oft in meiner freizeit an
ja noch mehr sag ich mal erläutert ich
habe mir natürlich auf meinem smartphone
ein paar informationen darauf
geschrieben und zwar soll ich anfangen
mit dem ersten bürgermeister
ich nehme mal kurz entspannte stellung
ein ja aber da komme ich zu punkt nummer
eins und zwei junge 2
ja weil hier kommt zu pumpen um 1 und
zwar weißt du was ich so richtig schön
für mädchen
wenn zum beispiel mädchen sagt walla
mach mich diese nutzen oder so sagt
bruder schwer
ich finde es richtig cool weil das macht
halt nicht leute ihr müsst euch das
vorstellen das ist halt dann einzigartig
sage ich mal
das machen nicht jedes mädchen und sowas
das ist für mich so weit nicht eine art
von einzigartigkeit weißt du sagt sie
nummer zwei was ich so richtig an
missions liebe und das so richtig ab
glücklich so feine wenn diese rap hören
richtigen hardcore rap viele mädchen
traut sich ja nicht so mit zu singen
aber mädchen ja so hatten gestern den
ganzen text auswendig kennen killer ball
direkt titanic herkommen jockey andrasch
für den gleichen geschmack okay leute
kommen wir zum dritten punkt ist wieder
dran
kannst du das machen ja kann ich auch
okay leute kommen wir zu punkt nummer
drei
und zwar schade weil mädchen
langweiligsten nicht viel trinken und
diese mädchen die wirklich immer wenn
man feiern geht richtig hart kurz danach
killer vor allem die sind so betrugen
wollen ja noch nachher kunst oder so
abgezogen nicht nur besoffen und
gekürzte haus ich muss sie 200
das war normal 80ern ziehen
an denen das wasser wenn du das siehst
schreibe ich mal feiern was ich so
richtig sexy finden ist diese diesem
like peace diese mike capps anhaben so
richtig enge leggins welcher sich schuh
darf natürlich nicht fehlen
der superstar adidas und das sind dann
genau die mädchen die nur mit herum
ich lag nur mit rum starter pack wenn
ich zwei denken so als ich mit 16 jahren
im alten kurpark war okay leute und
kommen jetzt zu punkt 5 oder 4 keine
ahnung auf den hab ich mich am meisten
freut und zwar finde ich es auch wieder
wieder richtig einzigartig wenn der
mädchen was mit mehreren jungs
gleichzeitig hat weil dann kann man
immer wenn man jetzt einer von mehreren
jungs ist sich denken jetzt zeige ich
richtig dass ich der beste bin und so
weiß das ist also ein ansporn soll ich
machen einem die so in ein mädchen
verliebt sei und das müssen sie noch was
gleich mit fünf sechs anderen hatten am
besten noch vier davon sind meine besten
freunde man kann ein richtig anhalt
heute jetzt bin ich froh er nicht mal
diese punkte loswerden zu können und so
was liebe ich wirklich total mädchen und
ich kann euch auch sagen es ist wirklich
jeder junge so also alle mädchen die so
sind kommen bei jedem jungen gut an weil
alle jungs das gleiche lieben an sonst
würde ich sagen das video hat euch
gefallen und ihr lasst mal kräftig die
daumen nach oben da werde mich
persönlich sehr freuen
also leute abonniert harwich noch am
ende des videos also genau jetzt erste
link in der video beschreibung und dann
muss eine bestrafung machen häufig peace